you
so now i can lower into my in-house
voice
thank you
so
in the case of lucky 7 the winnings w2g
is triggered when a player wins a prize
of 1200 or more minus the cost of the
ticket
the check second change in the bill is
in section 2 of the bill and it adds
licensed charity gaming facilities to to
locations where charities may sell lucky
seven tickets
a charity selling lucky seven tickets at
a cherry gaming facility would be
limited to
only 10 days per month
and there are others who are going to be
able to answer more technical questions
to these two changes
if the committee has
has any
i do have five other bills that i have
to introduce so if it's
if it's okay for the chair if i could
scoot and and i'm also chair of energy
right now but i do have people that that
can ask you can
that would be fine
okay
and the only other pink card
is from rick newman
from the new hampshire charity gaming
operators association
thank you mr chairman uh i appreciate
the opportunity to be here i
anticipate being fairly brief my name is
rick newman i represent the new
hampshire
charitable gaming operators association
we do support the bill
um
the um
i just will quickly address the reasons
why the the first section of the bill
that deals with
the current requirement that all prizes
have to be paid
by check
uh does create some problems
uh in certain circumstances so think
about
when a charity
is conducting uh selling lucky seven
tickets
at a facility
uh where the facility under current law
is allowed to for instance sell lucky
seven tickets from noon until
uh one in the morning i think it is
there's not always a charity person
present at that
location necessarily and so if somebody
wins a prize how do you give them a
check the check has to come from the
charity
and either the charity ends up leaving
signed checks behind which really isn't
a good idea
um or you know you got to tell a
customer you got to come back tomorrow
or you know and and the real reason for
wanting the check is documentation and
making sure that the lottery can keep
track of where the money goes and i
think you know adding eliminating the
check requirement and adding the w2g
uh requirement and make sure that that
documentation is available to the
lottery for audit covers the
documentation
issue
the second part of the bill
currently uh
well the second part of the bill allows
uh
licensed charity gaming facilities under
rsa287d
which are commonly known as poker rooms
to have
uh to sell lucky seven tickets
now currently
they can do that but they have to get a
second license they have to get a
commercial bingo hall license to do that
and then they have to operate a bingo
game
i will tell you that there are at least
four facilities right now that are
charity gaming facilities that that do
that they sell lucky seven tickets on a
regular basis
and they are they offer a bingo game
but nobody ever plays to bingo
i mean it's just you know they literally
open it up they
they they call for players players don't
come and then
they're allowed to offer the sale of
lucky seven tickets
it's cumbersome it costs money you pay
for a license that you don't need
you've got to have volunteers there that
you don't need
and so this change
would allow those facilities to sell the
lucky sevens without being required to
offer a bingo game it's the only it's
it's limited to the
potentially 16
games of chance facilities that the
state has as i said currently four of
them
um do it i don't think all of them would
do it my guess is it'd probably be five
or six additional ones that would so we
do support the bill and we'd ask for
your
support
yeah thank you mr chair thanks rick um
so
is would it would it allow uh electronic
transmission of the funds of the
winnings to the
charities
well you can do that you can do that you
can do that now okay you can do that now
the only uh the difference is it
eliminates the requirement
that it shall be paid by check
so you can you could do electronic funds
transfer or however you did it whether
you did it by cash or whatever
you would fill out a w-2g where
appropriate and then that documentation
would be available for audit
by the commission
okay that helps i got one more follow-up
so
okay i agree with you that there's four
four of the charitable gaming 16
charitable gaming locations have
have bingo
and most of those also have the machines
not neces they're not there with the
pull tabs correct
um
but but there's also so there's charlie
gaming locations there's bingo halls
that are licensed there's x number of
those
and then there's all the other uh
you know
vfws lions clubs or whatever
that also offer bingo
now
would this change
is that this change only going to affect
the charitable gaming locations and not
to impact the others that's correct it
would only affect the charitable gaming
locations there are i believe 11
commercial bingo halls this bill does
not affect them in any way and last i
counted there were about 140
locations like vfws legions right
private clubs where they sell lucky
seven tickets and by the way just to be
clear in those locations you don't need
to have bingo to sell lucky seven you
just sell them from the time you open in
the morning till the time you close
so
okay
one last question then mr chair so
it's my understanding you know a lot of
these locations
that have bingo i mean technically the
terrible locations that have bingo
have the machines
and my read is that they use them all
there's no way of monitoring that
how do they stop this customer going
there and using the machine
uh unless they turn them off but i don't
think they turn them off is that a quick
is that a correct assessment of what's
going on now that's correct that
basically says okay look let's just
let's just say let's get let's make that
what they're doing legal
is that is that correct yeah i think it
i mean it is the four locations that
have it i can tell you that i checked
with all of them
none of them have
like had a two-hour bingo game in the
last couple of years you know that's
it's they open it up they say we're
having bingo is available
nobody plays and then
they turn on the machine so
the term i used to hear when i was in
the house years ago is codifying what's
going on i mean codifying what's
actually happening in the industry
and allowing those facilities to have
them without having to go through
essentially the charade
of a bingo game that doesn't exist right
and mr chair
um okay but but you're saying it does
it's not going to impact bingo halls
it's not going to impact all the other
charitable organizations correct that
okay just wanted to make sure that thank
you
representative nunes thank you mr
chairman thank you for being here uh the
w2g requirement that's a requirement
anyway isn't it yes okay so just
removing the excuse me follow up mr
chair
uh removing the check doesn't stop that
information from going on over the way
it's supposed to that's correct it's
just that we're adding language here
that does say specifically that you have
to make that available to the lottery
so which i mean i would assume the
lottery could probably get that today
anyway if they wanted it but we're
making it clear in the statute that when
you have w2g information it's got to be
auditable by the lottery so they can see
it thank you
represent almighty followed by
representative lang
thank you on just follow up to that one
before
my real question
on i believe that the w2g requirement is
for six hundred dollars
so there would yes i'm being knotted at
by
are different levels for each type of
gambling in the irs statute
and like for instance 600
is paramutual it's 300 times the bet or
600 right that's per
for lucky sevens
um it's twelve hundred dollars for poker
for instance it's five thousand dollars
so there are differing
categories which the irs designates and
i did double check that yesterday and
it's 1200 for 12 for lucky seven yeah
follow up just to follow up on that one
it's twelve hundred dollars for lucky
seven so there would be no documentation
other than the record of the cash prize
thank you
i know i had another question which is
uh these charitable gaming facilities i
think it's only eight of them are going
to be able to open up
these uh slot machines historic horse
racing machines
on
i don't know why mine hasn't opened up
yet
and
that
this
lucky seven has been
transmogrified
uh over the years into
a slow
version of a slot machine which legally
makes it not a slot machine but
it is essentially the same kind of thing
well
it's just what the player might want
there are there are facilities
where they probably wouldn't have them
at all i would as i said i don't think
all 16
would have the lucky sevens but there
would be places where people might
there'd be customers who are used to
playing them
they like the way they play they like
the different graphic or whatever it
might be so i could see a facility would
have
you know
50 historic racing machines perhaps 10
or 15 lucky 7
machines in a separate part of the room
there may be some that wouldn't do it of
course but
and if a facility as you indicated
representative there may very well be
facilities that do not for whatever
reason
end up having historic racing and in
those locations
having those lucky sevens available
would be
important to them because it would give
the electronic opportunity for their
customers
thank you
representative thank you mr chair and i
do want to the chair is is director
mcintyre going to be speaking because i
have a question for him so i'd like to
have him
i'll hold one question back for him but
i'm going to be asking him to come up
thank you so um so mr newman my question
is this is i read this bill and i listen
to your testimony and i want to make
sure i'm clear and understanding what
the bill does this bill streamlines the
processes for the charity organizations
and will potentially increase the
revenues for the charity organization is
that a fair assessment what this bill
does it is thank you
any further questions
for mr newman
saying none thank you mr chairman
i'm former representative fran
winderball and then i'll have
thank you mr chairman
good morning everybody it's nice to be
back before you it's been a while
um
for the record my name is fran wendell
beau i represent powerhouse gaming which
is an electronic gaming company
first off i have to say
we've had many discussions over the
years about slot machines and it's been
clearly established that lucky seven
machines are not slot machines i play
slot machines in vegas
and i've played
the
lucky seven electronic machines and
while they look similar
the whole concept
payouts and so on are totally totally
different
and the
electronic machines in new hampshire
are legal with the definition in
statutory law
and i will also add they're very
convenient versus those little paper
tickets that you have to
break open
i have
not great vision
and to see the results up on a well-lit
screen
in big letters is a real advantage to me
i also have some
hand mobility issues
with my aging decrepitness
and
tearing open tickets is also very
difficult and the electronic saves you
that
i really don't have much to add to what
mr newman added he did a very clear job
but
representative lang used the word
streamlining it's absolutely true that
this streamlines the process
it reminds me that maybe
one day in the legislature somebody said
we should require that they play music
by cassette deck one hour every day to
have
gaming charitable gaming
well i think i i don't know that many of
us regularly use cassette decks anymore
well
many of us don't play bingo anymore and
this system has involved evolved that
there are bingo halls they tend to be
bigger games they have bigger payouts
and people really go out of their way to
go to them specifically for bingo
this doesn't impact the local clubs that
they're mostly for social purposes but
it does get rid of having to go through
the game of saying okay bingo is open
nobody's there for bingo nobody's there
to listen to cassette music
but
so it's time to update the processes
this committee has done many other areas
of charitable gaming over recent years
so um i ask that you support
senate bill 316. and that's all i have
to add be happy to answer any questions
you may have
thank you for testimony questions from
the committee
saying none thank you
thank you mr chairman mr mcintyre
do you have anything to
uh good morning mr chairman members of
the committee uh
my name is charlie mcintyre a privilege
of being director of the lottery and
with me is
valerie king our director of licensing
and enforcement
we neither support nor oppose this bill
certainly but happy to answer your
questions of technical nature you folks
thank you mr chair a simple question uh
mr uh mcintyre
why is lucky seven and bingo linked in
any way shape or form i don't understand
the logic
that would be historical when val was
there
minus one point
but yeah it is just historical because
they were traditionally the paper
tickets that some of the tickets are
played in conjunction with a bingo game
so it's just
follow-up
so basically there's no logical reason
there's no reason for it to stay that
representative romney
thank you mr chair um
welcome
uh in the fiscal note
you say and i'm sure you wrote this it
says it would likely reduce the number
of games of chance facilities that
offer bingo games
as many many of these games are
presently offered only for the purpose
of winning lucky seven sales
but again
we're talking about just the games of
chance hall the 16 games of chance halls
right so
which don't really do bingo anyway right
and if they do it's to very little
amounts so it would be it would be a
decrease but not material decrease i
think is the way we would describe it
and as a follow-up i just want to ask
both of you
being the experts
again this just impacts the charitable
gaming halls not the bingo halls or the
or the other organizations that you play
bingo
from your reading of the bill i i which
part are you referring to the 500 checks
taking away the bingo requirement yeah
right they would still be able to at the
bingo hall still be able to play them in
conjunction they could have the paper
tickets they can have the electronic
tickets so this wouldn't negatively
impact anyone i guess follow-up i just
want to restate it then so
this bill for the charitable hud
basically says you don't need bingo to
do play lucky seven
but that would not that that doesn't
transcend over to the other two
categories that you're still going to
need bingo to sell lucky seven at the
other facilities
bingo halls correct because this only
allowed you to sell them so in the end
you'll be able to sell them at your
fraternal halls you'll be able to sell
them at your bingo halls and now you'll
be able to also sell them at your games
of chance halls
but follow up and show me sure i
understand this
so at the fraternal halls and at the
bingo halls and there's what 15 of those
and this
endless number of fraternal halls
my understanding is that they couldn't
sell lucky seven unless they had bingo
going on is that correct correct and
that will not change that will not
change okay that's all i want to know
thank you
further questions
uh representative
thank you
and
first
i just want to ask on if this is a
correct way to explain it
the
lucky seven tickets used to be something
that was integral to bingo
bingo is a paper game lucky seven
tickets were a paper game
now
lucky seven has been almost entirely
turned into a machine game
which increases addiction
on and um
and so there is no longer a reason to
to
certainly i think we agree with the
first two clauses of your sentence
comment but the second two certainly
i think we do
in terms of lucky seven sort of
traditional paper sales i think it's at
least half of
our existing
lucky seven
sales so to suggest that it's done away
with it is is just not not this is
inaccurate
and i know that
the folks who do sell bingo tickets
derive significantly more revenue from
lucky sales 57 sales than they do bingo
and they use the paper tickets these
paper tickets yeah
and my
my real question that i had
was
on
if we go
from a five hundred dollar
limit requiring documentation to a
twelve hundred dollar
limit
requiring documentation does that bother
you at all
certainly not the 500 limit is rather
unnatural um
the
we as a lottery are amongst those the
largest in the state in terms of having
to be compliant with federal tax code uh
we're under gambling
and we over comply for example like we
regardless of how much you pay for your
ticket we will give you a w-2g at 600
even though it might be less than 300
times the wager as mr
500 dollars may have been a lot of money
back in the day it is not now for us so
it doesn't really
concern us obviously it's a paper trail
is what we're looking for
to
make sure money hasn't been laundered is
important to us but at these levels
you're not talking
money laundering is an issue
and also it just removes the requirement
for the check it doesn't mean we can't
thank you
any further questions
representative lyon
thank you mr director so would you
characterize the same way we talked
about before that this is a streamlining
bill to bring things into compliance
with federal code and also potentially
will generate more revenue for charities
across the state yeah certainly um it
also does away with what we used to call
ghost bingo which was they did a bingo
game when they opened that was the only
bingo game they did
it was you know just
it was to comply with a statue that was
it didn't serve a purpose so yes
understand thank you thank you mr chair
any further questions seeing none thank
you
anybody else wish to testify for or
against senate bill 316.
saying none i'm closing the public
hearing on
we're going to open the public hearing
on senate bill 318-fn
extending the hours in which games a
chance
and
senator before you leave could you fill
out a pink card
i just arrived i was over in the senate
passing all the legislation you folks
said
so
later
good morning mr chair and the entire
committee for the record my name is
harold french i'm senator for district
7.
i'm here to introduce today briefly
senate bill 318.
this bill as
was read is the extension of games of
chance of operations
and it's to allow the hours to change to
accommodate more people who are
interested in gaming
and participating it changes the hours
from 11 a.m back down to 8 a.m and from
1 a.m to 4 a.m the following day uh
simple bill and there are people behind
me that would like to take you right
would you answer any questions i
certainly would represent
thank you mr chair uh thank you senator
french for taking my question simple
question
um municipal rules ordinances would
override this so if a municipality said
an ordinance that says
our businesses can only stop until 2am
would that would that override
the bill
which municipalities have that well i
know i believe it's out in the seacoast
right now they have some
ordinances relative to
um establishments past 1am
and so my question is a local ordinance
would take precedent in this case so
while we allow it though they could
create more stringent rules i
i'm not sure uh i'm really not i know
there's
i didn't know municipalities had on and
it says like 24-hour gas stations are
open
uh 24-hour restaurants are open i am not
aware of
any that have that regulation but those
behind me could probably answer that
actually i was just pointing out that he
asked the question that that i had but
would you mind if we just made sure that
the municipals could overrule that
since a all-night
gambling hall
in a place that closed down regularly by
1am or earlier
was
not able to
keep people up
we do have
downtowns now that have
it would be up to you sure
thank you thank you
representative schomburg
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
for taking my question
uh
the change from 1 a.m to 4 a.m
what is the reasoning behind that
pretty much to accommodate
various working schedules for people
that would like to partic uh participate
and money generation i'm sure thank you
senator i was looking at my friend
across from rockingham over here
representative murphy
thank you mr chairman and thank you
senator french for taking my question
um my question is a follow-up to
representatives question
if we're going to open it and expand it
those extra six hours why not go to 24
7.
if you'd like to make that as an
amendment i'm sure it'd be acceptable
i'm just wondering about the traffic or
the flow coming through or is it
different or
i personally don't go to these gaming
places so i don't know
nor do i thank you thank you
eruption indonesian
thank you mr chairman
thank you for taking our questions um i
guess um i'm i'm looking at maybe uh
splitting the difference here and maybe
earlier is fine to help schedules but
going to 4am i guess i'd be concerned
about
more people
driving late possibly drunk um
so do we really need to go from one a.m
to four a.m
i'm not sure about the liquor laws but
isn't uh
service ending at one a.m
mr chair i can answer that question i i
just called the liquor commission before
i came here yes it's it's 1am so
actually it would give them time to
thank you senator thank you oh i'm sorry
uh represent elmi thank you does this
mean the liquor commission is going to
have to
have a night shift
no the hours division
the hours for uh serving would remain
the
thank you very much chair and to the
committee i appreciate your time thank
you senator
okay
from powerhouse
in support of the bill
thank you again for the record fran
wendell beau um new hampton representing
powerhouse gaming
you know i think this is what in the old
days we called enabling legislation
i doubt
any facility other than maybe right on
the border
with massachusetts or summertime in the
seacoast
would do this i i really
can't imagine up in berlin them opening
a facility that would be open until four
o'clock in the morning um so i i think
it would be limited it wouldn't be the
usual um i can tell you however when
i've been in vegas and haven't been able
to fall asleep i've not been you know
get up and go down and gamble a little
and then go back up and go to bed so but
that's
that's vegas i mean and even then the
place is empty although i will tell you
i ran into former representative david
lawton at three o'clock in the morning
um at one of these vegas casinos but to
compare what we have in new hampshire
even the biggest facility is such a far
stretch i think that they'll come to
realize that there's not going to be a
lot of people wanting to gamble at 3 00
a.m
it enables them to do so if they find a
market
don't think there's a lot of market but
i'm not opposed to expanded hours thank
you
answer any questions
representative
thank you
on we have a major labor shortage which
is going to be continuing for some time
it looks like
i think again enabling legislation
obviously if you can't get people to
staff it you're not going to take the
option of staying later perhaps it might
be something on a friday night saturday
night would be the only nights they'd
even begin to consider it but again i
view this mainly as enabling legislation
i doubt many will take us up on it
further questions
uh representative romney
thank you mr chair thank you
so again
4 a.m that just seems
so on new hampshire i mean we have
liquor liquor sales to 1 o'clock we're
not new york city where the bars close
at four in the morning
we're not vegas
and this is terrible gaming we gotta
let's not forget this is terrible gaming
this is not big casino gaming
so i i i'm just trying to understand and
like i agree with you i mean this is
it's enabling it says it's uh it doesn't
say shall
it says may
so they the organizations can do what
they want but i i think
i don't know i i just don't like the
appearance of us
keeping these open until four
uh do you
you personally obviously don't have a
problem with that
uh staying up to four
i often go to bed about then um
you know there are people who are
employed that get out of work at
midnight one o'clock in the morning and
often a lot of times those people have
to unwind for a while before they're
ready to actually go to bed
people like that i think would take
advantage of this
facilities that would take advantage of
it i think like i said
probably not many of them and it might
just be limited to weekends holidays
summertime but i don't think in the
middle of the winter most of these would
be wanting to be open till four in the
morning
okay thank you thank you
representatively
nonetheless snowed in
um
previously it was asked whether or not
town ordinances would override
uh another bill would town ordinances
override the permissibility that is
granted in this bill so if a town says
every business has to close at two
o'clock
then representative owerry in that
situation personally
not speaking for my client personally i
think that even though we're not a home
rule state i think the local ordinance
should take precedent and um i certainly
think if you wanted to put
something in there if there is a
specific ordinance the ordinance would
take precedent
um
but that would be a town vote and and so
on i don't think many towns would object
they've already approved charitable
gaming in their location but it's
something definitely to consider
thank you ma'am
representative
thank you mr chairman
thank you for taking my question
um
do you can you tell us
historically why they may have
originally done the uh 11 a.m to 1 p.m
do you have why those were chosen
i think some wise legislator back in the
days decided that those were appropriate
hours
that's i don't think maybe the lottery
would have
additional information i when it was a
starting point it was like anything new
for example lottery
new hampshire led the path on scratch
tickets well back then scratch tickets
were much different and they have
evolved over time and i think this is
just
another indication of evolving
to expand ours they
they picked a number and thought what
was reasonable back then but as we know
my my has the world changed since that
was enacted
thank you
rob's unknowns
thank you mr chairman thank you ms
wendell both for being here for us today
it's good to see you um
many years ago when i was a youngster i
worked the night shift for several years
my hours were from 10 at night to six in
the morning and there was one bar in our
neighborhood that opened at six o'clock
in the morning so all of us would get
off work and we would go over there at
six o'clock in the morning have a drink
and then go home
this is sort of similar to that someone
may work until midnight and then want to
go in they may not be able to make it by
one o'clock in the morning if they
wanted to go participate in charitable
gaming for an hour
so this just extends those hours so they
may have an availability to do that
exactly thank you
any further questions representative
thank you i'm not sure you'll be
answering this question i'm put on my
zoning board chairman hat that i wear
sometimes my question is this when
businesses go in
to a given municipality they generally
have to go through a planning board
process and get a site plan review and
one of the things that generally deals
with is parking and hours of operation
and that's set in the business rules
that allows them to get their their
certificate of occupancy or whatever it
is they have to get so my question is
that even if we extended these hours and
the site plan review was done by a given
municipality that set the hours of
operation as part of that site plan any
business that was looking to take
advantage of this would have to go get a
modification at the local level for that
site plan review to increase the hours
is that correct
that's normally how it's done i would
agree thank you
any further questions
is testifying for the bill
from the new hampshire charity gaming
operators
thank you mr chairman uh rick newman i
represent the new hampshire charitable
gaming operators association and we do
support
uh this bill
um i
many of the questions touched on the
points i was going to make and i don't
want to take up your time but i will
tell you the
question of uh representative almy asked
about
you know is there anybody looking for
this does somebody want this
and the answer that is clearly yes um
many of
the game operators as
uh
fran windable said
are on the southern tier of the state
and compete directly
these days and will compete even more
once historic racing is operating which
is going to happen in the next probably
two three four months we're going to
start seeing that come out from a bill
that you folks passed a year ago and
when that happens
that competition is going to be even
more direct and it and they compete
directly with
you know the everett casino
and as representative nunez pointed out
and i myself were in that boat when i
was a state representative here in 1979
uh and in the 80s i drove a taxi in
portsmouth and i got out i left here
during the day went home
drove cab from five to midnight at one
o'clock in the morning and that's when i
got out of work so
i totally i've always sympathized with
people who work you know the odd shift
not everybody works eight to five
and uh so what we see now is
uh
losing customers who will get out of
work at midnight and it's not a far
drive down to everett it's an easy drive
at that time of the night so once you
lose a customer in the gambling business
like in any other entertainment business
sometimes you lose them forever that
means you're going to lose them on
saturday afternoon too they're going to
become a part of the rewards program
at whether it's oxford casino in maine
or the everett casino and that's where
they are become a loyal customer to
and i think this gives the ability to
those facilities that want to and see an
opportunity to keep those customers here
in new hampshire giving money to
charities to the state and to our game
operators and our employees
i will also say uh that i totally agree
that not every room is going to do this
i mean it just won't make sense for
every room to do it but it certainly
makes sense for every room to have the
opportunity i could foresee for instance
a place like belmont where
they probably wouldn't do it on a
regular basis but on a
perhaps a new year's eve
event or some other special event maybe
during nascar weekend
when
you have a hundred thousand people up
there going to races i could see them
extending their hours for those periods
of time and those would be
you know they could be very lucrative
uh so
uh you know for those reasons we would
ask that you
uh support the bill
and one other point i want to make is
thinking about the differences because
every room is different so hampton beach
for instance the operator down there
said to me you know i'd i probably
wouldn't and oh that brings me to
representative wang
and i think the answer to your question
in my opinion is that yeah the municipal
ordinance would certainly take
precedence
hampton is a very good example of that
they have an ordinance that businesses
of entertainment
have to close at 1am
and so my operator down there said to me
you know this wouldn't i wouldn't be
extending my hours but
on a rainy day in july when when the
tourists are at hampton beach at eight
nine ten o'clock in the morning with
nothing to do i could see opening up for
breakfast having a breakfast tournament
or you know breakfast uh gaming having
peeps something for people to do so
hampton would probably be one that would
take advantage of the earlier opening
and not not the later opening
so just thinking about the differences
of all the rooms i think
this will be beneficial to everybody
involved
representative rodney thanks chair thank
you rick
so
you mentioned encore in oxford so
what are the regulations in
massachusetts and maine are they allowed
to stay open 24 hours they are
24 hours a day thank you
any further questions
representative ames
[Music]
i i guess i'm still concerned about the
back and forth on ours and i mean
municipal ordinances in particular and
what uh
what
what uh is the governing
rule in the event of the
place that has an ordinance that
specifically limits the time for this
kind of establishment to
let's say 1am
and then along comes this bill that says
um that
the
facility
uh running these kinds of games may stay
open until
4pm
4 am it's a direct conflict with a
municipal ordinance
and if i were
in your shoes
i would want legal advice in that
situation and it seems to me that
if we're going to go forward with this
then it's really important to put in
here a municipal option
that makes clear you know
that there is a way to
solve this problem and avoid conflict
by
enabling municipalities
to
um
well enabling facility operators
to comply with a municipal or ordinance
if it's set at a lower level
something like that
yeah i don't i i don't think i'd
necessarily disagree uh representative
that
um
if there were some language i'd just be
concerned i'd want the language to be
broad and not uh carving out uh charity
gaming
uh but like for instance i've read the
hampton ordinance it covers all it's got
a it defines what entertainment is it
covers it says dance and singing music
that sort of thing service of food
um so clearly hampton
you know that's been in place for a long
time so they have the ability to do that
now
um if a community wanted to
enact something like that
um my guess is my people would
voluntarily go along with it anyway
because they want good relations with
the municipality they're not going to
want to get into a war over the three
hours but uh
but i don't think you should carve out
one
business
further questions or comments
representative nunes
oh representative alani yes i don't
really understand what you're saying
on
we're talking about
these
games of chance
on
would you be saying that we ought
ought to just pass a law saying that all
municipalities
laws about when they can businesses can
be open are
uh
are going to
preempt any
state law
no
and i don't think you could i mean
i want to stop i want to be careful i'm
not an attorney so i don't want to
pretend to be one
but no i wouldn't i would not support
are you all set
i'm not sure what we're talking about
then but thank you
any further questions comments
thank you thank you testimony anybody
else
oh
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee i thought maybe i could help
solve some some of the questions my name
is robert clegg i'm representing boston
billiards in nashua
and i can tell you that for a fact
nothing in this bill stops anybody in
any town from saying no
whatever the current ordinances are
zoning regulations planning board
whatever they still have to be complied
with
the only thing that they have to do is
go in and ask for a change in their
hours if they want one
and no town i don't see anything in this
bill that would force a town to say yes
as far as why do they want the extra
hours
it was mentioned here a lot of people
get out of work at 11 o'clock
they don't have any place to go
some of them like to go to the gaming
places they can still get a sandwich
they can get a drink
and get a coke too and they can play
cards and try to unwind
it's not it's not vegas
but it's a place that's pretty friendly
and and
the bedding is is low
so people are just looking online and
you know i've met some guys at some of
these locations that were on the
ambulance all day
and if you're on the ambulance
all day and you're picking up people
that have opioid
issues and and you're picking up
accident victims you need some place to
go before you go home
and all these guys are doing is saying
let us keep going for that second and
third shift
but but i guess the biggest concern is
whether or not the ordinances on the
local level stay they stay just as they
are
no community gives up its ability to
regulate
the businesses whatsoever
i'll take any questions if you have any
missed channel
okay any questions represent alani
thank you
i come from a town in which
a poker game has taken over a flower
shop
in
a local mall that is semi-residential
semi-residential with subsidized people
and
on
we were not allowed
by the law that passed
to
rethink the idea that
this was going to turn into a slot
parlor
which it will in a few months
and
i do not understand why
in this particular law
the locals would be allowed
to prevail
it worked interesting
all night
could you explain that to me i
understand the question mr chairman i'm
going to say that the community that you
speak of didn't have an ordinance
already in place
so when the law came in and allowed for
the for the program or for the for the
operation of any particular business
because you had nothing that said it
couldn't
you were told that they could
um any community can can make ordinances
but anybody that's in there is
grandfathered
so the idea that the poker room became
something else was because even after
you let it in
before it expanded
there doesn't appear to be and i i don't
know what your town is but
more than likely nobody went in there
and said it can't get any bigger than
this
if that's the case then a
a community that doesn't have that prior
ordinance
would not be able to
say no to a game of chance organization
that wanted to run games until four a.m
is that correct
my understanding of the of the system is
that if your community doesn't choose to
regulate it then it runs unregulated and
that's for anything whether it's a game
of chance or or um
a representative line followed by
representing early
okay so we're getting a little little
confusing here now i want to try to make
sure i'm clear on what we're talking
about
from from your testimony it sounds like
a business that's gone through a site
plan review through the planning board
when they want to open a business they
go to the planning board say i'm opening
my business and they go through a site
plan review part of that site plan
review can include hours of operation
if they wanted to change those hours of
operation based on the new law they
would have to go back in front of the
planning board
in order to get a modification to the
site plan review is that what your
testimony was
planning board or board of aldermen
anybody who has the authority to make
the changes based on whatever zone
they're in yes thank you
representative
would you believe that in a amendment to
this
indicating what you just said that
nothing in this bill shall
uh prohibit the local
community ordinances from overriding the
hours of operation
in some general terminology
would do you believe that the proponents
of this bill would find that uh
generally acceptable
i'm not sure it depends on what you say
because if the way you said it if that's
what you put in
and they decide in two years to change
the hours does that mean i now have to
to give up my time you know you know
what i do for a living this is just my
fun
when when i build a facility or i
convert a facility into something
i need to make sure that those people
for five years have
what it is they thought they had so if
you're saying that somebody can make an
ordinance after the fact and now it
affects me i'd have an issue with that
all right follow up well let's take a
concrete example we're both familiar
with there's so a mall in our town
it's got this nice facility that would
make a very nice bar or
a gaming
facility the site plan for that
property says uh
i think
eight to
nine or something like that hours of
operation
that would essentially prevent anyone
from using
one of those storefronts
as a
charitable gaming operation would that
be correct
unless they had the ability to go before
the boards the zoning board of the
planning board in our town and make
their case and somebody thought it was
the best use of the property
and of course anybody that was in that
area who was in a butter of any sort
would also be able to come to the the
planning board and the zoning board to
express whether they thought it was a
good idea or thought it was a bad idea
well if any of the neighbors of st
patrick's cemetery came to the planning
you're all set yes thank you sir
any further questions uh representative
schamberg thank you mr chairman
thank you for taking my question
can constitutionally can the legislature
draft legislation that could overrule
what representative lang has been
stating about
the town or the city says hey
you're going to shut down at one o'clock
the legislature only
the cities and towns only have
the power that the legislature grants
them so if the legislature decided to
take away their ability to have zoning
and planning
they could write a law and they could
take away
all the power of this of the the local
communities
thank you sir
thank you mr clarke thank you sir
anybody else wish to testify for or
against senate bill 318.
saying none
i'm closing the public hearing on senate
okay
okay i'm opening the public hearing on
senate bill 343
establishing a committee to study room
occupancy tax revenue
and fees and the formula for
distribution to municipalities
senator hennessey
is the prime sponsor and
before you leave senator could you fill
out the pink card
my apologies mr chairman
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee erin hennessey i am the state
center for district one which is the
northern half of grafton county and all
of coast county
i brought this bill forward at the
request of one of my beautiful towns
gorham in north eastern coast county
they are a small town that has a lot of
different
destination attractions they have um
and so they have a lot of hotel rooms
and even though this legislative
legislature did some great work
last year with uh senator rashady's work
on sb 99 in the inclusion of 30 percent
back to our towns in meals and rooms
revenues
i think there's still more work that we
can do in identifying where those
specifically rooms revenues come from
and helping to send those revenues back
to the towns that send that money to the
state
rooms revenues
put more of a
burden on our localities because of the
infrastructure that involves from
sidewalks
local roads
and also first responder expenses that
these these
cause to our local communities
and so this is a study committee
and one of the things that this
legislature did and i i think it was
back in maybe 16 and some of you may
have been a part of that study committee
was actually studied this previously but
the department of revenue at that time
did not have a system in place that
could identify where room's revenue
comes from
so i'm happy to report that the rim
system is in place and the department
now can collect that information however
the way that they collect the
information is not done that way right
now so you could own three different
hotels across new hampshire
and report your revenue from your
business office not in any of those
locations
so we don't know where the actual
revenue is coming from so this study
committee will take a look at
studying modifying the tax revenue
distribution formula
for room occupancy based on where the
revenue is collected
it'll look at taxpayer information
requirements that would be need to be
mandated to facilitate the modification
of revenue distribution
it'll look at identifying the cost to
the department of revenue administration
to ch change forms and systems to
collect that tax location data
identifying barriers if any for
taxpayers to report data by location
and it also does one other thing it um
the senate amended this bill to
incorporate
a
bill from the senator from district five
and that's
looking at the impact of a two dollar
municipal occupancy fee and how that fee
would be reported collected and managed
by the municipality
i'm happy to take questions
thank you for your testimony
representative romney yeah thank you mr
chair thank you senator appreciate you
being here
so
we get this well this is a this is a
commission a study committee bill
but we get this kind of bill about every
other year uh requesting these these
things one of two things either
reallocate the way the uh rooms tax is
allocated back to the towns
or
which is the your your roman five which
is the the amendment that happened in
your committee
the two dollar
add-on tax uh hampton and portsmouth
push for this all the time
so i i'm just trying to understand why
we want to have a study on this versus
just file a bill and let us fight it out
again
uh i mean again we we've been here for
those of us who've been around for a
while we've we've dealt with this issue
i guess the new piece of information is
the
is the revenue uh the rim system
because that has always especially when
it came to meals it was all the meals
part of the tax it was always very
difficult to
separate out
you know a guy owns
you know 50 dunkin donuts he reports it
in one location
so i i don't know i i i know you're
doing this for a stitch when it sounds
do you
do you feel the study is really going to
be change anything i i guess you do you
filed a bill but yeah
so thank you for the question i think
that the questions that you just posed
would result in this committee saying we
don't have all the information we've
just heard from a bunch of businesses
that this would be hard on them to
change the way they report their revenue
to the state we heard from the
department of revenue that this is going
to
perhaps cost something and i don't know
the answer to that to change their
system or to what the timeline would be
for different businesses in the state to
file this information what the forms
would need to be changed
and then you get all that information
and you'll be like i don't think this
bill is ready for prime time i think we
actually need to study this hear from
the different
taxpayers in the state to find out
exactly what it would take for them to
file
the forms appropriately so that we can
identify as a state where our revenues
is coming from and i think that's
another thing in general that the
legislature needs to look at is when we
make decisions
we don't we don't actually know exactly
where all of our revenue is coming from
i can tell you that gorham sends a lot
of revenue back and they do not get they
don't
based on what the town has told me in
rooms and meals tax they get back what
one restaurant in gorham pays
and that's that's very difficult to for
the town
follow up yeah thank you
so
so if we do it for this tax
she i guess the question becomes should
we do it for every tax you know
a good example would be cigarette
sales we know there's a lot more
cigarette sales that go on on the border
towns
like like the chairman's place style i i
see it myself in portsmouth people come
and
with the register that has all the
cartons of cigarettes people are buying
because they're coming from other
locales
so
so should those towns argue the same
thing you know well we sell more
cigarettes so we should get more of the
cigarette revenue i think that's you see
what i'm saying
i think it's a slippery slope a little
bit yep no that's a great point as a
district that
um borders vermont maine and canada i'd
be happy for you to include that in this
bill
okay that wasn't my attention but thank
you
further questions
next is greg moore
representing american for prosperity in
new hampshire
all right
anybody else we're so that's another
that's the next bill
representative tucker
later
okay
i wasn't going to speak on this because
i knew senator hennessey would really
cover everything but i think the
difference between cigarette taxes
and rooms and meals tax is that the
revenue is that comes back to places
like gorham is based on their population
so they have a tremendous number of
people who come
mostly in the summer but more and more
year round
and
they have hotels
not that many restaurants but a lot of
hotel rooms motel rooms now airbnb
and
short-term rentals
they get very little because their
population is really quite
small and that that isn't true that
there's a relationship between
cigarette it goes into
has nothing to do with the population so
towns in cowas county particularly
and in upper grafton
think that
they have a lot of expenses
to do with
um
hosting
visitors
including police
first responders as she said
and they get very little back
for what they spend and it's
those things are listed in the town
report you know and all the state
forms that list it so
residents
in addition to the selectmen
and the treasurer people like that
residents are very aware of what they
see as a large disparity
i think there may be a difference
between what is reasonable
as a
payback to these towns from rooms
and meals and we really don't know that
that i think is very much part of the
study so i that's why i'm on this as a
co-sponsor
and i
certainly hope that you endorse this
study
would you take questions oh yes
representative lyon
so i guess when i'm looking at this bill
i know we've heard
i believe you were on the committee my
first term and and we heard this we
heard the two dollar bill uh two dollar
tax bill on municipalities allowing that
before
and i'm just struggling to to figure out
what new information would possibly come
out of the study committee that we
haven't heard and last and at least my
three terms on ways and means
around this conversation and adjusting
the formula specifically
um i know i struggle with the concept of
i'll get to my question mr chair i just
want to stage i i struggled the question
of
of allotting more to a given town
because it raised it when in fact i'll
use my town as an example we have 93
running through us my ambulance goes on
93 on a regular basis to deal with
people who are heading north because
they get in a car accident
or they hit they hit something and so my
town's first responders have to go out
and deal with that on a regular basis
even though we have absolutely no
revenue coming in but we have a we have
an absolute expense
i'm sure you
send bills to them so my struggle is my
struggle is understanding why we won't
treat all towns equally instead try to
manipulate the bill and what is the
overriding factor that needs a study
committee that's going to change
i think that rims does provide a
possibility
of
maintaining
privacy to specific businesses but
making it possible to know
how much each town
and
the locations of where revenue is coming
from i think there could be a difference
between the percentage that goes back
to the population between rooms and
meals and that is very specifically why
i signed on to this bill i think we
should know whether that's
possible people in the north country
generally tend to think that they ought
that rooms
more rooms money should come back
than meals
i think it's worth studying i think that
rims gives us an opportunity to find
more information
about
what our business and tourist
business particularly
generates in the way of revenue for
new hampshire it's a growing industry
and we know from the pandemic that
downs are been heavily affected
by
the pandemic and the number of people
who are coming to their communities
gorham feels like it was overwhelmed in
2020 almost
and it caused a lot of difficulties so i
specifically did hear senator hennessey
when she appeared before the gorham
selectmen you know as a sort of routine
i'm a senator do you have concerns
and very specifically the town manager
and the selectmen mentioned the concern
of rooms and meals so it isn't just sort
of any constituent or business this is a
town that felt beleaguered and as though
the state
could
have the possibility of helping more in
the distribution formula
and asked her to sponsor such bill
thank you for taking my question
uh robert and elmi
thank you i'm not going to give my
speech about the
problems of urban hubs that have hotels
and take care of the services for
everybody around them for free
but
on i did want to be able to to ask
before we finish whether rims is
we're going to have the d.r.a okay
you have a question for representative
tucker
no just uh sympathy
well i do have a very specific other
myself
one of my constituent towns is carroll
and carroll is made up of twin mountain
and bretton woods
bratton woods
has the omni mount washington hotel and
they have just tremendous rooms and
meals revenue
carol only has 723
people
so
their distribution for all of the work
that they do
in hosting those uh
visitors and on summer weekends it can
be up to 10 000 people
so
they get very little money with only a
723 or 25 or 50
residents that's the multiplier
and it seems grossly unfair to those
towns that are very very small
that
their revenue is
based on their population their small
populations with very
specific and large expenses to be the
host
representative eugene
thank you representative for taking my
question um i can understand what you're
talking about with the distribution
however
even though these towns may be small the
fact that they have
this uh commerce going on is benefiting
residents who who work there so i would
think there's employment opportunities
if there's 10 000 people showing up uh
in that area on a weekend aren't they
spending money in the area helping small
businesses
so that you're getting benefit in those
ways
aren't you that's right but it doesn't
generate revenue
for the municipality that's the
difference it generates
good things for the businesses and we're
all for that
but specifically
a municipality
has to provide services
for
these people and they aren't getting any
revenue directly from it and they don't
get
you know there isn't any direct
business tax that comes to the
mississippi
so that's that's where the gap is and
that i think is worth studying
because
i think the north country more and more
we we have declining population
so
we have a declining population and the
revenue source that we help the state
generate
only comes back on the basis
of the population of the towns that are
generating that revenue and that i think
is worth studying
representative romney yeah thank you i
was going to wait for the work session
to have this conversation but real quick
but i wouldn't want to be paying the
property tax bill of the omni hotel
mount washington hotel or the or
brentwood ski area
i'm sure they're huge
so the town is getting revenue for the
fact that those businesses are there
because if they weren't there they
wouldn't be getting that kind of revenue
so bratton woods is and carol are very
lucky of course
but they still feel beleaguered by the
very specific costs that they have
i will
i have of course next to my desk at home
the
town reports and i will come up with if
we have a work session i'll bring
bring information specifically based on
a forum which i do not represent and
carol i think that those two towns are
interesting that'll be interesting to
see what kind of property tax they're
paying thank you happy to do that
any further questions
saying none i'd like to have the dra
good morning
mr chair members of the committee
carolyn lear i'm the assistant
commissioner at the department of
revenue happy to answer your questions
right the first thing is
when
a
say a hotel owner
files his bill
would you be able to determine
if he has six hotels or six motels or
whatever it is that's spread out over
the whole state we'd be able to
determine
which one
is associated with each
town
so
currently
the rims system is not built to require
an operator to schedule out their
revenue in that fashion
that because that information isn't
currently necessary
for purposes of calculating the tax or
the distribution as it exists in law
the system could certainly be
modified
to collect that information
and that would not be a heavy lift
on our end
but as you know
from the legislative history of this
issue there's been several bills to
require
reporting m r revenue on that fashion
and those bills have all
failed to date um so we've not
proactively taken the step which i think
would be counter to your intent thus far
to require reporting in that fashion
thank you questions from the committee
representative romney followed by
representative uh
elneny but we've had these i think
we've had these discussions in the past
you know usually revolves more around
the restaurants when it came to
prorating out
uh you know the dunkin donut guide
around 50 stores
uh and they want it that way it was it
was it was the legislation that passed
that fact that we have consolidated
under what you term would be
consolidated reporting
of all the stores and i'm sure there are
folks that own multiple hotels as well
it could be a chain
marriotts or whatever they may and i
don't know if they do or not but they
may report if they're owned by the same
probably franchise but
but
they report so if we were to undo that
that would be because we did that for
convenience for them in terms of filing
their taxes
so would that create a burden
for those businesses that have to now
report out separately
all of the where the revenue comes from
thank you
yeah i think that that has been the crux
of the debate in the past on the issue
um i can't speak personally to the
burden
on those businesses but i think i'm just
looking at my list i think we've
considered about five bills in the past
you know seven or so years that would
have required
scheduling out and certainly
i recall that the businesses testified
representative elmi
thank you mr chairman
carolyn if on this bill for the first
time only asks for
the hotels
and
it seems likely that anybody that owned
multiple hotels would also have quite a
bit of administrative competence
to be able to
to provide you the breakdown
on
i don't know what they're going to have
to say about this but uh
wouldn't that make it a lot easier and
if if it was easier on them would it
also on
how much difficulty would you have
putting it into the system if we changed
for hotels
i don't
from a system perspective i don't
believe that it would be technically
difficult it would make the form longer
because presumably there would need to
be more lines so that each operator
could schedule out each of their
locations
i suspect there would be a small cost to
make those changes but i don't think
it's substantial enough for it to impact
your decision making
it would probably be in the tens of
thousands of dollars not the hundreds of
thousands of dollars to program that
change
anybody else wish to testify
saying none
i'll close the public hearing on senate
this is representative tucker's card
doubles from the less belt oh tucker
but you want to give it to uh yeah there
okay
yes
hey
okay
how are you doing
i'd also like
steve roberts
okay
yes
hey i'm going to open a public hearing
on senate bill 435-fn
an act relative to the net operating
loss carryover under the business
profits tax
representation senator geiger is the
prime sponsor senator geider is here to
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee for the record bob guida
senator from district 2
so senate bill 435
addresses a problem that new hampshire
exclusively had it was the only state
that
essentially
double apportioned taxation
on the net operating loss carryover am i
on the right bill
yeah i am yeah yeah sorry too many bills
not enough time
um
and so in the interests of
both rationalizing our taxation system
to the irs code uh
most current 2018 i believe and
remedying this
exclusivity which is actually detriment
to business environment
we brought forth senate bill 435
and that's what it does basically it
stops the double apportionment
function or function of
uh
of the net operating loss carryover
application
i'm happy to take any questions
thank you for your testimony senator
greiter questions representative me
thank you i'm going to keep asking this
question until someone explains it well
on
can you explain the process of double
apportionment
no the dra can
so we're gonna have to wait for them to
know what we're talking about
i think
most people haven't dealt with it yet
here
yeah we had the same question in the
senate and so i'll defer to their
expertise at the risk of saying
something inappropriate not
inappropriate but incorrect
so that's where i go with that thank you
representative lange
thank you and if i'm not mistaken
besides the double apportionment issue
it deals with updating the irs code to
the most current code that is currently
we specify a specific year is that
correct right thank you
further questions
mr chairman representative schamberg
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
for taking this question uh
you mentioned that
this is a detriment to the business
environment
i've heard from ways and means members
in here that
when we reduce the bpt by one-tenth of
one percent to 7.5
my correct representativeness yes
that businesses would
flock here
because of the reduction
is this a counter i mean i i'm confused
a little bit uh
are they coming or not coming are they
staying are they leaving because of this
uh
of this
nold
thank you for the question
i would submit that businesses are not
coming but it's not because of our tax
structure
okay they're not coming because we don't
have a labor pool we don't have
workforce housing and those are issues
that are being addressed in other
legislation from other committees both
in the senate and the house
but when you are the only state out of
that does the double apportionment of
the tax
that sets you apart from the rest of the
country and that is
against our favor as being as a business
environment okay so
uh to answer your question
businesses are trying to come here but
they're turning away for other reasons
that our tax structure which we hope to
improve yet again this uh this term yeah
representative
thank you senator gaida
aren't we also
by far
the most dependent
tax
state
on the business taxes
for our budgets
we are very dependent on business taxes
which is why it makes a great deal of
sense to be business friendly and reduce
those taxes to watch the revenues
increase
right we're a 240 million dollar surplus
right now and who knows april hasn't
rolled in yet
again whatever we can do to help
businesses
ultimately
helps those that don't have jobs because
businesses like to create jobs they like
to grow markets like to expand their
product lines and do those things so
anything we can do to better that
environment which is already
very good in new england and amongst the
best in the united states will continue
to attract the businesses that will
provide employment and help take people
off welfare roles and give them homes
and things like that
follow-up
shouldn't we try to attract our
workforce
more than
businesses at this point so that the
businesses we've got aren't suffering
and the property tax is one of the main
reasons that the housing
market is really difficult i would i
would challenge the question that
property taxes are the
prime source of difficulty lack of
inventory there's nothing for sale the
state
that's the reason rents are so high and
prices of houses are out through the
roof
and again the more houses we can build
as we restrict
uh
or as we release reduce the restrictions
against housing either locally or
statewide i think we'll be better off
that's that's not driven by the property
any further questions
thank you senator geiger thank you mr
chairman
the next
is jim
uss eglio
um
from the national
chamber of commerce in support of the
bill
and if you would say your name sure uh
jim euselio
so i know it's hard to pronounce or
euselio
so good morning everyone my name is
jimmy salio i am a cpa
and tax practitioner and i'm here to
represent the greater nashua chamber of
commerce
and so
i'm here to um i should also say that i
was a member of the commission to study
new hampshire business taxes back in
and one of the recommendations of that
report of that commission was to fix
this double apportionment issue for the
nols and so i'm glad to see that that's
being addressed here
um and so the chamber fully supports
that effects of the double
pushment of the nol
excuse me so i'm not here to talk about
that what i wanted to kind of just
highlight this morning is the change to
the internal revenue code reference and
i'm really specifically
talking about smaller businesses
so the apportionment fix is really in my
mind geared toward the larger businesses
that do business in and out of the state
of new hampshire so whether it's a
domestic company or foreign company if
it does business in and out and it
has sufficient nexus in other states
they have to apportion their income and
so this fixes that and gets the answer
to the right answer that it should be
but excuse me for the smaller businesses
that don't apportion their income that's
really what i wanted to speak about
because
this bill again the apportionment issue
for the businesses in new hampshire like
a main street
landscapers restaurants bars that don't
apportion their income this appointment
fix has no bearing on them but what this
bill will do as passed will impose a new
80 limitation on the use of nols and so
i want to make sure that you've thought
that through
um
so just for some background here
the tax cuts and jobs act from 2017
changed the federal annual rules and so
before the tax cuts and jobs act there
was no 80 percent cap in nols you you
could just use your federal nol
there was also a two-year carry-back in
the 20-year carry forward period and so
many of the provisions of the tax cuts
and jobs act were very favorable such as
the decrease in tax rates and so forth
and so one of the things that the
federal law did to help i guess raise
revenue a bit to offset all those tax
cuts was to implement an 80 limitation
on the use of nols
and so that i would say is unfavorable
but what it did i guess to soften the
blow was it changed the carry forward
period from 20 years forward to
indefinite and so i think in the fair
that because the federal or the code now
has this 80 limitation businesses may i
guess conceptually may not be able to
use all their nos because they could go
expired if there's a cap now
and so under the internal revenue code
as of 18 the carry forward period is
unlimited
and so
for new hampshire of what this bill does
is it
it now
follows the internal revenue code as of
2018 because it defaults to the bbt code
so again it could change in the future
if we adopt a different code in the
future to to to tie to
but it doesn't change the carry forward
period right we have a 10-year carry
forward period so under federal law now
they have this 80 cap
and an unlimited carry forward period
we're picking the worst of both we're
now imposing this 80 cap and we still
have a 10-year carry forward period
and so just to kind of give you two
examples to highlight this
conceptually if a business makes a
hundred thousand i'm sorry if a business
loses a hundred thousand dollars in year
one in year two it makes a hundred
thousand dollars
over that two year period it's made
nothing right it's broken even and so
you would expect that company to pay no
taxes
mechanically how that works is a company
if it lost a hundred thousand dollars in
year one it would file a tax return with
that one hundred thousand dollar net
operating loss which gets carried
forward to the subsequent year in year
two they're going to file a tax return a
hundred thousand dollars a profit
they then can deduct that hundred
thousand dollar carryover from the prior
year and they come to zero income no tax
so it makes sense
but what this bill would do and it's
effective in 2022 would say
that company that lost a hundred
thousand dollars files tax return has it
and i will carry forward over a hundred
thousand dollars but in year two when it
makes a hundred thousand dollars we're
going to make you pay tax because we're
only going to allow you to deduct up to
eighty percent of your taxable income
and so we're going to create twenty
thousand dollars of taxable income
and you're going to pay a tax and then
you can carry that nol that rest of that
now that we disallowed to the next year
and you can only do that for 10 years
and so put it in more real terms if you
think through what's happened recently
against especially for smaller
businesses
because of the pandemic if a small
business
lost money over the last few years and
you can kind of pick a number but say a
lot it lost three hundred thousand
dollars over the last two or three years
and then in 2022 it starts to turn the
corner and it makes a hundred thousand
dollars
you would think that that company
shouldn't have to pay taxes because it
just lost three hundred thousand dollars
it survived the pandemic
it turns the corner makes a hundred
thousand dollars in 2022 but this law
would say you know what you can only
deduct up to eighty percent of that loss
that you are carrying forward and so
you're going to have twenty thousand
dollars in 2022 a taxable income and
you're gonna have to pay the tax and you
can carry forward that other the rest of
the nol
and it just gets worse if you then think
about what happens next year
next year the companies turned the
corner it makes another hundred thousand
dollars in 2023. they get the exact same
answer they're still going to have to
pay a tax next year because this 80
limitation that that's going to be every
year they have this and so they start
out with a 300 000 loss for the last few
years survive the pandemic make some
money in 2022 but can only deduct up to
80 percent of the income and so my
example they'd come out of 2022 with a
220 000 nol carry forward to 2023 they
make some another hundred thousand
dollars but they can only deduct up to
80 percent of the income in 2023 and
they're gonna have to pay a tax and then
before you know it the ten year goes
away
and they might lose some of their
annuals because of this 80 limitation
and so again
my perspective is the fixed the double
apportionment is a great thing
but for the smaller businesses that
don't apportion their income that has no
bearing on anything it doesn't matter to
them the only thing that's going to
affect them is this 80 limitation and so
what you could do is what you've done in
other situations where you adopt the
internal revenue code which is decoupled
from that provision i mean we do it all
the time we we adopt the code every few
years the department puts out what
changes that has on the bbt and then we
disallow say bonus depreciation and so
you could certainly decouple from this
80 percent limitation if that's what you
want to do
again because if you don't
again
although we're fixing the double
apportionment issue we still have a
10-year carry forward period and a 10
million dollar cap which i understand
there's budget issues that you know you
may have to live with that but then to
throw on to that an 80 limitation it's
just not it's not as good as what it
could be and so i want to make sure that
you think that through for the new
hampshire businesses that don't
apportion their income
so hopefully i was clear and can answer
very helpful thank you questions from
the committee
representative elmi
followed by representative i had a
couple the first one is quite specific
on don't aren't we already decoupled
from that provision so this bill would
be reversing that
well we had we're going to adopt the
section 172 of the code in effect as of
12 31 18
and so that's what we're going to follow
what what what our what our
77-848 says is
we specifically have a 10-year carry
fold in a 10-year cap and so in that
regard we decouple but not with regards
to the 80 limitation
yes but what i'm saying is we don't need
to decouple from
from that we already are decoupled
no not with respect to the 80
limitation the cap
right now we don't we don't have that
cap because we follow the code as in
1996. so that's this 80 limitation
doesn't exist today it exists if this
bill passes yes that's what i'm saying
okay we just need to kill that part of
the bill in order
to keep decoupled
right you could kill that part of the
bill
if you don't want the 80 just like you
have a 10-year carry forward and a 10
million cap you could come up with
language to get rid of the 80
taxable income if that's what you choose
okay
and
could could i have
well it's it's not really a follow-up
it's a second question
if he could explain
double apportionment as it is practiced
in in new hampshire over a period of
years say you've got that
uh
you've got a business
that
that on
was apportioned three years ago
on at
34 of its business
and then the next year at
28 of its business and
and so forth how would that affect
uh
affect this bill
right so again i look at this bill as
two components we have this 80 issue but
it's kind of it's buried in this code
okay the apportionment issue
so right so this issue has existed as
long as i can remember
and it's just the way
it's because of how the statute is
crafted
so
most states you can either you can
handle an nol at a state level different
ways
some states make you apportion the loss
in the year incurred
and then you apply that
a portion loss to your um
post-apportioned income and so it's
apples and apples you apportion your
loss
wherever state you're in 50
and then that apportion loss gets
carried forward and it is applied to
your portioned income in the subsequent
year so it's apples and apples
the way in some states have a
pre-apportion they'll take your no l
they won't have you apportion it they'll
let you carry over to another year and
it comes in pre-apportionment so again
it's apples and apples you can either do
it kind of pre-apportion or post a
portion
we
do we do it in either way what we say is
we make you apportion your loss in the
year you occur the loss carry that
forward but because of the way the
statutes written you start out with your
business prop your gross business
profits and then you layer in your 77 84
adjustments to arrive at taxable income
which then gets apportioned
the nol is a 70 74 adjustment so you
start out with gross business profits
you then bring in your post portion loss
in arriving at taxable income that gets
apportioned
and so it's because it's an a4
adjustment and it just happens to be how
it's how we craft our statute you always
start with gross business profits you
add your a4 adjustments to arrive at
taxable profits then you apportion it
and so because we say that that loss
gets a portion in the year that's
incurred
you start out with kind of a
post-portion loss but then you have to
layer it into
you add it to your business profits to
arrive at taxable profits
that then gets a portion so it's because
this is this
it's because it's an a4 adjustment
effectively
representative rodney
thank you mr chair thank you for your
testimony
i just want to go back to the
uh the 80 cap and the 10 year carry
forward so
current currently without doing anything
because we don't conform to the 2018
code correct right so
so right now
what is it again i want to make sure i
understand is it is it the worst of all
world or is it is it
do we have the do we have a cap
now
we have a we have the 10-year carry
forward and a 10 million dollar cap of
an nol in a given year so so 10 million
right cap
in any given year and then a 10 year
carry forward right so again so i know
in the commission we suggested that if
feasible you know you may want to change
that to make the state more competitive
with other states
but again i realize it's a big revenue
issue
but but it exists okay but if if we
follow go ahead if we follow if we do
conform
as the irs
languages
then it would be an 80 cap
and no
no limitation on the carry forward years
is that what we're looking at no if you
if you adopted 18 code
yeah normally there would be an 80 cap
like there now is under federal law
right federal law also to help i think
taxpayers because of the
80 cap that they were forcing on people
said you can carry forward unlimited
years it used to be 20 years carried
forward they say unlimited
but new hampshire
explicitly says right in the statute
that the losses can only be carried
forward for 10 years and so i don't see
that changing that's what it says and
the bill and the bill and in the current
statute okay yep
but if we adopted if we had if you
adopted it i think the only irs it would
be unlimited no i think it would be 10
years as it says it would oh right in
the bill
so we have to adjust the bill to if we
want to totally conform to the feds what
yeah if you wanted to
have an 80 cap
and you wanted to
conform to the fed i guess you could
have an unlimited carry forward period
right
versus keeping the 10 years and just
getting rid of the 80
just like it is today i mean that's what
the law is today there's no cap and it's
a 10-year carry forward provision okay
represent indonesia
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um so just to
understand
if we had if we keep a 10-year cap let's
say you have a business that has a huge
loss
in the first year
such that
over 10 years they still haven't
completely made up that loss
if we
stay with the 10-year cap then then in
that case that business wouldn't be able
to recoup that so
right i don't know how often that occurs
is do you have a sense of whether that's
a yeah i don't know maybe the department
can answer that my sense is it doesn't
have it would have to probably be a
larger company that um
you know the loss was large enough um
and their profit over the next 10 years
was not enough to absorb that loss
thank you but again having the the cap
is just now going to exacerbate that
because
again if you do my example um
they can't use those nls like we can
today every year it's going to be
limited to 80 of their income so
so it may increase
the losses okay
just before we go further
to your knowledge
with this with this bill as is
would it be a disadvantage to the small
companies more than to the large
companies or would it be
would there be any advantage
well i would answer it this way the
the small companies i would say
generally
don't a portion of income i was i would
think a lot by and large because they
just do business in new hampshire the
small businesses they just if you just
do business in new hampshire and you
don't apportion
there's only one thing that comes out of
this bill it's a bad answer they have
this 80 cap if you if you're large
and you will portion your income this is
a this is a good bill because it fixes
the double apportionment issue which is
key to them and so if you're a large
business
okay the 80 cap isn't great but at least
we got rid of the double apportionment
issue so that's that's good for the
large larger businesses but if you have
a small business on main street that
doesn't apportion
this apportionment issue is a non-factor
the only
the only effect is the 80 cap
okay
representative scheinberg
thank you mr chairman
thank you for taking my question jim
over here
i'm sorry okay
uh i would like to know mr chairman
could the gentleman
provide since we don't have a white
board here could he provide on paper
just a
a a demonstration of these
blocks of how
what you talked about was just
so smooth
you didn't get stuck anywhere but some
of our minds are stuck right now
i just
could you provide us
an example
you know a drawing of something for the
future maybe what i can do is have
another speaker come up and i can just
die no no no you you could put put it
together and send it to us oh okay i can
do that
thank you that'd be great okay
representative elmi
thank you um there was one glitch in
your explanation
on given
that most of our people haven't had to
deal with this before and i don't even
remember this
on
the a4 adjustments what are they
so
[Music]
so the formula for new hampshire's
taxable business profits is you start
out with gross business profits which is
generally federal taxable income
so that's your starting point
these are all defined terms in the
statute
so you start out generally with federal
taxable income and then we have specific
adjustments under 77 a4 like a separate
entity adjustment like our compensation
deduction
to arrive at new hampshire taxable
profits so you start with gross business
profits you have these a4 adjustments to
arrive at taxable business profits which
then gets apportioned
in arriving at new hampshire portion
taxable income
and so we have i can't recall
how many for adjustments there are but
there may be a dozen or so and one of
thank you so
it's the business tax section
of the business profits tax
and it's on something a4
is where we look for the list
right it's specifically 77 a4
thank you
any further questions
thank you you're welcome thank you and
if you'll send us yep i can do that
appreciate it thank you
i've been asked
i have
two sets of
pink cards and they want to come up
together
so the first set
bruce
berkey and angela
cattell
next era energy mr chairman okay
mr chairman for your record my name is
bruce berkey
with she infinity capital group here in
town and we represent next
era energy resources
a uh
the majority owner of seabrook station
and also operating and
bruce can you speak into the mike please
we can barely hear you sorry
uh
we represent next year energy resources
uh operating in approximately 40 states
across the country
and they are the majority owner of
seabrook station in seabrook new
hampshire and with me today is angela
batali
and she is the senior director of state
tax policy for nextera energy and she's
based out of florida and she's enjoying
our lovely weather today so
i will
hand things over to angela and
i think she'll be able to give some
perspective from a multi-state
corporation
[Music]
thank you bruce
mr chairman members of the committee
thank you for the opportunity to speak
to you today
um
i won't go into our company background
since mr berkey did a good job of that
except to say that we are also in
addition to our ownership of seabrook
a the largest renewable energy generator
in in the world from wind and sun and a
world
leader in battery storage
my name is angela pitali as has been
said i am a tax professional
my whole career has been as a tax
professional and i now focus just on
state tax policy
and the reason we're here today is
because new hampshire is a
an outlier
from every other state in their
treatment of
not operating losses
sb 435 would help to remedy that
situation
from a policy perspective not operating
losses are intended to even out the
differences between
business cycles which don't fit in to a
tax year and
necessary but arbitrarily created tax
years so you have business cycles you
have startup companies that generate
losses over periods of time
and these cycles don't fit into a tax
year but you have to have a tax year in
order to file your tax returns
and the purpose of noels is to even out
the federal law and other states limit
that policy goal by imposing things such
as the 80 percent limitation that has
been discussed
but no other state in the nation
imposes the double apportionment that
new hampshire does
doing so in some cases renders net
operating loss is virtually worthless
especially when coupled with the other
limitations that have already been
discussed
and this subverts the worthy policy goal
of net operating losses and evening out
those business cycles for taxpayers and
it makes new hampshire uncompetitive
compared to other states in that regard
and with that i am happy to take any
questions from the members
thank you for your testimony questions
representative
yes how frequently does seabrook
thank you for that question
representative almi
that's a complicated question because we
are a very large
complicated company
seabrook does not file a tax return in
new hampshire in a vacuum it files
as part of a larger
consolidated group
so seabrook is just one piece of our tax
return filing that we file in new
hampshire
further question okay representative
romney oh
thank you thank you for your testimony
isn't seabrook owned by multiple
companies yes we're a majority of them
okay thank you
approximately ninety percent nine
percent thank you
representative
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um so you said that
new hampshire is an outlier in terms of
how we handle
net operating loss the uh the 10-year
provision
that's still in this bill does that
still make it an outlier even if we
adopted this bill
yes 10 years is very short compared to
most other states many states have a
20-year carry forward period consistent
with the prior federal law and many
states have now
conformed to the federal law and have an
unlimited carry forward period thank you
representative almighty did you have
representative romney
so how does that work so again federal
law is 80 percent on an unlimited i'm
sorry i didn't hear that federal law
right now is what 80 and unlimited
yes federal law allows you to carry over
your net operating loss and in the
future year when you have income you can
offset eighty percent of that taxable
income in that particular year and
continue to carry forward the rest of it
forever
right and i
understand and i i think i understand
this because if you take 80 and you keep
on going 80 you never get to the total
amount correct well it's not 80 of the
loss it's 80 percent of the taxable
income that you generate in that future
year so if i have a hundred thousand
dollars
of
of an annual carry forward as as the
gentleman from the cpa society i'll use
his example if i have a hundred thousand
dollar loss in year one and i carry that
forward and i have a one hundred
thousand dollar taxable income
before anna wells in the next period
i can deduct
up to 80 percent of that taxable income
number so i can deduct 80 000
in that year the next year if i have a
hundred thousand dollars of income i can
deduct the rest of it which is the
twenty thousand dollars so it's it's not
the loss that you keep multiplying down
to never get to zero
income in the future that actually
further questions represent almighty
sorry i remembered what i wanted to ask
next which is
assuming that we're talking about the
entire
energy uh next year energy resources
conglomerate
that files
on
how often do you
i'm not i can't accurately answer that
question i i don't do our tax compliance
work so i i'm actually not sure of the
answer to that question
i apologize could i ask in a slight well
a slightly different question about the
same thing
which is
on
if a company
was large enough
that it had a
or
a net operating loss
uh
of over a million a year which i think
is our part of our cap
on
and
but
on
could not use
the credit
of the nol to get
further to get back
to
solvency
over a 10-year period would that company
well that would be very company specific
and really depend on their cash flows
and their other revenues um
you know not operating losses are not
necessarily
[Music]
well they are cash losses but oftentimes
expenses that the government grants to
them that are benefits for example
capital expensing
so i may go buy a piece of equipment
where under prior law i had to deduct
that slowly over a long period of time
from my income
today i can deduct that all in one year
and that gives me if i'm investing in a
huge piece of equipment or factory
equipment or something that gives me a
huge net operating loss in that year
i may be generating cash flow in future
years that i can still operate my
business but i may end up losing that
not operating loss so
it may or may not
cause
a company to go out of business that's
just very effects and circumstances
dependent
representation thank you mr chair and
thank you for taking my question so i
want to be clear on something you just
said because
in the end a net operating loss that's
carried forward ultimately be realized
if after a period of time
they become profitable i think we're
using a hundred thousand dollar example
so i make a hundred thousand dollar loss
in the first year but then i make a
profit in the second year of a hundred
thousand i can deduct that eighty eighty
thousand of the first year's loss in the
second year and then i can deduct the
full that what's left over is 20 grand
in the third year i can deduct that from
a hundred thousand dollars in profit and
i'm only paying taxes on eighty thousand
dollars is that my understanding of what
the way this plays out so in the end you
get your your full no well covered over
the course of the year and and
is that the way it plays out i guess
that's the federal treatment yes
new hampshire has additional limitations
that could impact that
um
which we're not really here to discuss
but you have the 10 million dollar carry
forward limitation
so for a large company that invests 100
million dollars in a plant
um
that can deduct that on day one they
only get to carry forward 10 million of
that loft so they automatically right
off the bat lose
90 million dollars of that that
deduction that benefit
um
and
uh then you have the 10-year carry
forward period so you have to assume
that you
you know generate enough income within
that 10-year period to use the losses
that you can carry forward
so the the double apportionment just
exacerbates you know the impact of those
other limitations that are already in
place one follow-up mr chair follow-up
so
how does that work on the federal side
right now so again you have that hundred
million dollar loss you could deduct
that in its entirety on the federal side
and then deduct it again in the state
side
on the federal side it works exactly as
you described a moment ago
um i'm sorry i'm not sure i understand
the question i guess my question is so
on the federal taxes that are owed
you would
we're using 100 million dollar example
you just use right way beyond new
hampshire's 10 million dollars but that
100 million dollar example
would still apply to the federal level
right so you would be able to deduct
that at the federal level but at the
state level you'd only be able to deduct
10 million dollars of that loss is that
is that what i understand you're saying
if you assume that the hundred million
dollars was equivalent to to your loss
you bernstein followed by
representatives
thank you mr chair and thank you for
coming to new hampshire to answer our
questions we appreciate it
the 10 million limit on the net
operating loss is
uh generally no
um
i think there may be one other state
pennsylvania has a sort of limitation
but it is not a strict dollar amount
it's a percentage of your future taxable
income similar to what federal does with
the 80 percent but pennsylvania's is 40
so you do get to carry that forward and
they have a 20-year carry-forward period
um but they have a
a lower percentage cap
um
but generally no other states do not do
that okay and then one more question mr
chair
regarding the 80 limitation have any
other states to your knowledge removed
that and become uh so they're not in
harmony with the internal revenue code
but
it's a little bit friendlier to
businesses um thank you for that
question
representative um
some states have adopted the 80 and some
states have not adopted i don't know how
many but there is a mixture not all
states have gone to the federal
calculation
there are many states who have remained
with their prior laws that were in place
before the tcja act adopted that okay
thank you mr chairman just a
clarification on that 100 million dollar
example
where new hampshire is limited to 10
million
um that
so now there's 90 million left so then
the next year
were you saying that that's it for on
that on that particular transaction or
the next year they'd have that 10
million
of the 90 million
no the limit
if you
if you assumed you had 100 million
dollar loss for whatever reason
you can only carry forward 10 million of
that the other 90 is gone forever you
never get to use that in new hampshire
okay
i want to remind the committee that we
will be having a work session
we do have
one two three
more
sets to go
so representative brownie
you know when i when i see thank you
when i see uh section 172 i think of
accelerated depreciation
this has nothing to do with that doesn't
it no 172 is the nol provisions 179 is
expected 179. thank you welcome
representative
yes on
so the 90 million is gone because the
federal form no longer contains that
depreciation right
no the 90 million is gone because new
hampshire law imposes a 10 million
dollar carry forward limitation on net
operating losses
but
we only recognize
those
okay
so new hampshire allows the deduction so
if you're in an income situation and you
take that full deduction you get the
full benefit but if you take that
deduction and it puts you in a net
operating loss position
then
effectively that 10 million dollar
limitation takes away the benefit of
that deduction that 90 million dollars
forever assuming that would put you in a
not operating lost position
but in that case if you invest a hundred
million dollars
uh in a
machine for seabrook
on
and we removed the 10 million deduction
requirement
then on we would be faced with a deficit
of 100 million dollars in our budget
well the 100 million dollars would be
the the loss not the tax amount you'd
have to apportion that
and then
apply the tax rate to get to the tax
number but we are not advocating that
you eliminate the 10 million dollar
deduction we're simply here
advocating that you eliminate the double
apportionment
any further questions
representative tucker
i guess i'd like to ask a question for
the work session
i don't
are there places in the new hampshire
tax code where we give greater benefit
this does sound like something
we'd want to back away from
and conform with the federal law but are
there places where
being a new hampshire taxpayer
is an advantage because we have
less onerous
taxes than the federal code so in other
words are we balancing something
through this or
is this something we really want to
eliminate so that's a that's really a
sort of a bigger question you might want
to ask the dra when we finally
get them to come up here good but
that's after a couple more cycles and
it is a quarter after 12.
any further questions of
these people
thank you
mr chair yes um
representative tucker there are a couple
of provisions that i can point out
one is 163 j of the internal revenue
code which is an interest expense
limitation
and
at the federal level there there's a
limitation on the amount of interest
expense that can be deducted and iowa d
cup i'm sorry new hampshire decouples
from that provision and allows the full
interest deduction
there's also the
global intangible low taxed income
provision in the federal internal
revenue code which i'm not an expert in
but requires taxation of some of the
which new hampshire also decouples from
but the problem with this
your your your um
[Music]
your
i apologize i may be misspeaking i'm
working on a similar bill in another
state and i may be confused so please
disregard that comment
um
i apologize my personal privilege
here is that
the example that you had with 100
million dollar loss
for the federal government they could
take the whole 100 million dollar loss
under both federal law and new hampshire
law you can
deduct i'm just a federal the federal
yes federal laws expense allows
100 expensing
of capital expenditure so if you invest
in a piece of equipment you get to
deduct that if it causes you to have a
nut operating loss you can carry that
forward and deduct it in future years
indefinitely and where new hampshire
starts
with the federal
number
that federal number shows the entire
hundred million dollar
removed from their profit so new
hampshire will stop
a smaller number now
let's say they had 10 million dollars
worth i mean
a hundred and
one million dollars worth of profit
they could deduct a hundred million
dollars from that they end up with one
million dollars worth of profit then new
hampshire would start and look at that
one million dollar profit and then go
forward
i just want to make sure that people
understand yes it's only in the case
where you have an nol that these
problems come into effect right correct
any further questions
representation union uh more just a a
question slash comment on what you just
said if there was a depreciation
um if that ended up that 100 million was
a depreciation but that depreciation
wasn't allowed in new hampshire
that could affect the answer
correct that's correct
so it might not be a million dollars
just interject something on that
representative romney yeah that's that's
why i bought i misspoke it was 179 we
don't conform to 179 either
we do have a cap
on 179. once 179 is a is a small uh
business
provision uh the 100 expenses expensing
that i'm referring to is under 168k
which is the depreciation section okay
thank you i'll talk to you and i was
just using that by way of an example for
the numbers not necessarily the specific
um deduction but
to represe just reflect what the problem
okay let me ask
i assume there's no more questions this
and thank you for your testimony let me
ask the committee
thank you for the opportunity go until
12 30
and then take a break
and then come back because we still have
uh
mr moore
and then the bia
and then the dra
i'd like to finish it if we um i think
we should just finish
up just finish up
okay then uh
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is greg
moore i'm a state director with
americans for prosperity here in new
hampshire
uh we support senate bill 435 largely
because it does get rid of the double
apportionment which is
again an outlier and it's a competitive
hindrance for the state
i don't want to
try to over ground it's already this
this committee's particularly when i'm
in between you and lunch
uh i mean that's the most dangerous
place to be
uh but i want to talk a little bit about
about what the gentleman from nashville
raised
because we were very involved in the tax
cut and jobs act process and part of the
reason for going to the 80 percent and
getting rid of the time limitation
was because it was part of an effort to
smooth the business cycles
and ultimately the goal was was to see a
little a lot less of the cyclicality in
fact there's a lot of programs at the
federal level where they're trying to
make the programs less dependent on a
business cycle
and so
that was part of the rationale for the
80 and eliminating the cap and
to the gentleman's point
if you're going to institute the 80 in
conformity i think it only makes sense
to get rid of the 10-year cap so that
you allow people the time to to get
those operating losses in perpetuity
until they're made whole eventually so
but there was a rationale for it it
wasn't just on the
on the the 10-year because as you know
in the federal level they budgeted out
10 years it wasn't just on on the
marking up of the bill
there was a rationale to try to smooth
out some of the business cycles during
the process of the discussion of the tax
cut and jobs act so i just wanted to
raise that out there and i'll stop with
that because like i said i know the
worst place to be is between reps and
lunch
okay
and i'd be happy to take any questions
all right
thank you for your
chair testimony
reptile bernstein hey um
forgive me for stretching this out but
explain to me how the 80 cap smooths out
the business cycle
because typically when you have a
recession you end up a lot with a lot of
businesses with net operating losses
and as you come out of that business
cycle the economy typically takes
uh i think they say as much as three
years typically come out of recession
before they reach their most robust
levels by stretching out
uh the stretching out those payments
you end up with a dynamic where where
the the
the cyclicality you don't see you don't
see a rapid spike
of immediate drop off and then you see
for two or three years a long a long
pause before you start to see the the
the money come back
so the revenue on the revenue side you
want to
find a way to
smooth those out and as we've seen at
the federal level
uh the
revenues tend to be pretty chaotic if
you were to look back over the last 30
years if just if you were to look at a
bar graph comparing new hampshire and
the u.s
the u.s the u.s revenue picture is is
much more of a
thing like this than new hampshire which
has been a lot smoother
probably thanks to the members of this
committee of course
well thank you for your answer and i
appreciate your brevity too thank you
any other questions
thank you thank you
very much
greg if you don't mind one more sorry
absolutely so i i want to take this off
the hot seat sorry almost almost i want
to talk about this um a question around
the 10-year carry forward um and lines
13 through i guess it's 13 through uh
24 of the bill i think is where where we
have a 10 million dollar cap and we have
a 10-year limitation
i think that's where that all comes into
play is it your inclination that that
puts us at a disadvantage if we leave
that language in
so if you if you keep the conformity
that's
in line 27 and 28 which is striking the
reference to the tax code of 1996
that would then make it just synced up
with the section 172. one of the one of
the challenges with that is
as we discussed in 2019 in the budget
which of course included
a number of provisions of conformity not
this particular one
is that
if you strike the provision as you see
in 27 and
2028 you end up with a dynamic where
if the federal government then in turn
changes its tax policy ours
automatically basically what we would
describe as incorporating by reference
um
so
obviously there
we would argue is getting rid of the
10-year cap if you're going to keep this
provision in place where you strike it
out but there are several options one be
to take this provision out in lines 27
and 28.
another provision would be the option
would be to
get rid of the 10-year cap and the third
option would be
to
get rid of 10-year cap and instead of
changing it to striking the reference
entirely
you change it to the to the tax code of
2018.
which at least means that if you're
going to
engage in further conformity efforts it
has to come through the legislative
process as opposed as opposed to simply
being incorporated by reference when
uh when the federal government makes a
policy change
i mean
there are a lot of ways to slice to
slice this but it's ultimately it's up
to you as to which way you want to go
with that
so just one follow-up mr chair follow-up
so again i guess i'm getting to the two
points that you made one was the 10-year
limitation one was the 10 million dollar
limitation and now those are outliers to
the federal government i i didn't make
the 10 million that was a prior speaker
i was talking about the 10-year
okay thank
we have two cards from the bia
thank you mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is dave
giuvam senior vice president for public
policy with the business and industry
association
and with me today is steve lawler he's
been before this committee many times
he's a partner at nathan wexler here in
concord
and he is also the chair of bia's fiscal
policy committee so we are here in favor
of the bill today uh many of you will
remember uh from the past a radio
personality named fred harvey and he
would always talk about a
something and then he'd pause and say
and now the rest of the story
so i'm here to present the rest of the
story the genesis of this bill and the
path it has taken uh so far this
legislative session to get to you
i fielded a call from one of our bia
members
last summer
saying um i've got a question about what
seems to be a sort of an odd new
hampshire quirk
and i said okay what what is it and she
goes well it involves net operating
losses and are you aware that
you know for multi-state companies they
have to apportion their nol the way they
apportion their taxes and i said yes i'm
aware that she goes well were you also
aware when they
take that deduction in subsequent years
they have to apportion it again
rendering it almost useless and i said
no i wasn't aware of that this is news
to me
so we disgusted our fiscal policy
committee and decided we would approach
the legislature to try and remove
that second nol apportionment and
representative all me i i trust you were
now
cognizant of what the second
apportionment is when we're talking
about it
so
we thought this was relatively simple we
approached senator bob gaida to be the
prime sponsor he agreed that
new hampshire was really
out of whack with every other state as
it were
as it relates to nol apportionments he
agreed to sponsor the bill
i thought this is easy peasy
so sometime in mid-december i'm sitting
at my desk i'm minding my own business
i'm not bothering anyone and i get a
call from senator bob guidan i say hello
good morning he goes bob gaida is not
happy
now if you're a lobbyist the last five
words you want to hear in the world is
bob guida is not happy
and so i asked him
what was the cause of his unhappiness
and he said when you sat down with me
you said you wanted to correct this
double apportionment issue and that's
what i agreed to
but the draft of the bill i just got
from uh legislative services you're also
removing the
10 million dollar threshold or cap and
the 10-year carry forward cap and do you
know what that is going to do to new
hampshire revenues
and i said
no but i imagine it's it's going to have
a significant impact
but you should know i never in the
language we drafted for legislative
services to use we never asked for that
we didn't ask for the removal of the cap
or the removal of the 10-year carry
forward and i don't want to call it a
drafting error because i don't think it
was i think it was a drafting
misunderstanding where they just removed
the whole section dealing with with
apportionment and in doing so it also
removed the cap and also removed the
carry forward provisions so they
redrafted
the bill which um we were beyond the
drafting deadlines at that point so it
had to be
the the bill was printed in the original
language with the understanding at the
senate hearing
this new amended version would be
offered by the sponsor
uh
dealing with what we wanted to deal with
which was that second nol apportionment
included in the the new amendment
something we did not ask for
was this updating of of the new
hampshire
tax codes to reflect the federal irs
2018 tax codes
we didn't ask for that
but i have to say we didn't strongly
object to it and i'd like to explain why
one reason is the tax code that we're
operating under right now i think is
from 1997.
and that's a long time ago and doesn't
really reflect
it's causing practitioners to to go back
to the 1997 irs code and somehow
rationalize that with their with their
current tax filings so we thought it
just is a general practice it wasn't a
bad idea
to
introduce
bringing new hampshire into compliance
with the 2018 irs code the second thing
it did and it's reflected in the
fiscal note
is it does bring
some revenue
back to new hampshire that would be lost
by just
getting rid of that second apportionment
so
it doesn't make the bill revenue neutral
the state would see
what i think is a small
loss in the grand scheme of things but
it does mitigate that loss
so um
i think that concludes my testimony
you've heard a lot about it
but let me quickly turn it over to steve
thank you very much
just for clarity purposes currently the
new hampshire
conforms to the 2018
irs code for most
of of the tax law however in this
statute
only the statute has
a reference to the 1996 code
so it was it was buried in that statute
it's it's
but currently
the tax code that we are following is
the 2018 for all
other aspects of the
business
profit tax
this is not a bill
that only affects those multinational
companies i mean this is a bill that
could affect
smaller businesses that may
sell
their their
their goods in more than one state it
could be a small business that sells
to vermont it could be a small business
that sells to another state
massachusetts
so it doesn't only affect
multinational businesses it does affect
businesses that do sell
to other states
i'm going to try to give you an example
of how this works
and i know there's been a couple
questions and there will be something
that will be
given to the committee but i'm going to
give you a really simple example so
let's talk about a business that in year
one loses a hundred thousand dollars
they
they file in two states they file in new
hampshire and they file in another state
and fifty percent of their income is new
hampshire and fifty percent of their
income is another state
so they have a hundred thousand dollar
gross loss
they apportion fifty percent of it so
fifty thousand dollars is a portion to
new hampshire
and that is their nol carry forward
year two
the business makes two hundred thousand
dollars gross profit
the way the current law works is the two
hundred thousand dollars is their gross
profit
the fifty thousand abortion loss is
applied to that gross profit
giving a uh net profit of a hundred
fifty thousand dollars
fifty of it is a apportioned to new
hampshire so that's 75 000 and 50 is
apportioned to the other state which is
75 000
so the the the business is going to pay
tax on 75 000
if we get rid of the double
apportionment
then that two hundred thousand dollar
income
is apportioned first so that two hundred
thousand dollar income is a portion to
new hampshire of fifty percent which is
a hundred thousand dollars and then we
apply
the fifty thousand dollar nol
which now means that the business will
only pay taxes on fifty thousand dollars
instead of the seventy five thousand
dollars they would have paid if this
double apportionment
is is happening so it's a simple example
um but if you can see that it does hurt
businesses because now they're they pay
extra taxes because they're really
and like i said it's
it's
it affects you know smaller business as
well as multinational businesses
and
as i said the we do conform to the 2018
code but is only in this provision of
the statute that the 1996 code is being
used
i've just been asked could you
draw that out into a diagram
and give it to the committee thank you
yeah
questions represent alani
yes on
i'd like to see that
example written down
and any any other that you thought was a
variant on it that would be interesting
i think that was very helpful
it's almost lunch and our brains are
going crazy
uh
uh mr chauvet that explanation of the
background
the origin of this bill was very helpful
and it really fits in with what my
understanding was as i entered into this
discussion
that this was really an attempt at what
you might call even a technical eff fix
a fix of of a provision that uh
was when you look closely at it
um
unfair
and it didn't make a lot of sense so
you're trying to get to it
an apportionment that's not a double
portion
and that sort of tells the story the way
i just said it
and as such and then the fixing of the
irs code reference
is
is extending a process that we began a
few years whenever we did it to conform
uh to the more recent irs code with some
exceptions that we thought through very
you know as carefully as we can in this
process
so that's the way i received this bill
and that's the way i'm looking at it
right now so it means that
we certainly can
be adventurous and go
go
further afield to big time changes but
that's not the way the senate treated it
and not the way it's coming here
and i guess i would
is that is what i just said constantly
with what you were trying to say
yes our our original
intent was specifically related to the
double apportionment issue which we
viewed as unfair and also inconsistent
with how every other state handles uh
nol apportionment um are thinking what
we recognize there likely would be a
fiscal impact which there is and it's
it's spelled out in your your fiscal
note but we thought
we're talking about a pretty small
universe of companies first of all we're
talking about multi-state companies and
then it's even smaller than that we're
talking about multi-state companies that
that suffer a loss and obviously that's
not every multi-state company so
our thinking was that this was the right
thing
for public policy for new hampshire to
do both for fairness and to make us
competitive with how other states are
treating this issue
everything else that we've spent most of
the hearing talking about were not
things that the bia asked for i would
say and you i think you're going to hear
from the dra
one question that hasn't come up is what
is the fiscal impact of removing that 10
million dollars and the 10-year carry
forward and i don't know if they have
those figures with them today but i can
tell you it is substantial so that's
something you have to measure i i would
love to argue that on behalf of
employers but you have to weigh that
with what the fiscal impact is and in
the impact that what that would have on
the new hampshire budget yeah good thank
thank you very
much now
good morning carolyn lear assistant
commissioner with the department of
revenue
i'm primarily happy to answer any of
your questions but if you would
um let me talk about conformity for a
minute because i think um
the history on how new hampshire has and
hasn't
conformed to the internal revenue code
is helpful
um and it's something that i've been
sort of working on with you all for a
while
so
you know in the early 2010s
new hampshire was in the practice
of not updating our
reference to the internal revenue code
on a regular basis and you know it's an
interesting question states do a number
of things
some states on the far extreme
automatically tie to any federal tax law
change as it's made
and that certainly has an element of
convenience but it also sort of
abdicates a lot of state control over
their tax code right because
you you have to affirmatively do
something to say no we don't want to
implement that change for new hampshire
purposes
on the other side of the spectrum
um our states who was sort of like where
new hampshire was where we um
either tied to a very outdated code or
in a couple of extremes didn't tie to a
code at all and just had you know their
own state level code essentially um
that's really administratively
problematic it's my understanding that
that's really difficult for taxpayers to
comply with
so sort of i don't know that any of
those extremes
are great
new hampshire has in recent history
sort of paved a middle ground
where we periodically update our
reference to the internal revenue code
while having a policy decision about
certain
important material items that we might
want to decouple with i think
representative abrami you've
mentioned a couple
bonus depreciation and
certain capital expense deductions under
179 those are areas where new hampshire
has had the policy discussion and made
the decision
to specifically decouple from those
provisions
what i would say about the second
portion of the bill which would conform
to
the
80 percent limitation
on nol uses
the 80 limitation being
the taxpayers ability
to um deduct no more than 80 percent of
their income utilizing a loss
i think the the first threshold question
we should have about that is is this a
material enough
impact
to
warrant specifically decoupling from and
currently
in our statutes we specifically decouple
from that treatment of nols by way of
referring to the code of i think it was
1997 is what we currently refer to now
is that a material enough item that it
makes sense to to continue to decouple
from that and i can't answer that
question for you but i think it's an
important threshold question to ask
because if we have if we start having a
policy conversation about every single
difference between the new hampshire
code and the federal code the list of
items that we're going to need to think
about on a yearly basis could get long
quickly
because the federal government is making
changes on sometimes a weekly or a
monthly basis to their federal code that
we then need to consider
i don't that that wasn't something that
i say hoping to lead you into a
particular
outcome i just think it's important to
keep in mind that
the list could get long if we start
considering each change
and with that i'm happy to answer any
questions
okay representative schomburg followed
by representative romney and alby
thank you mr chairman and thank you
assistant commissioner
uh in reading the fiscal note 22-2990
uh i noticed in page one
that you used the statement that diary
queried all ty 2019 taxpayers that
utilize an nold and on page three used
the same
first one was on double apportionment
the second one was on the 80 percent
of taxable income
in
doing this query did you
did the
dra
have this already in their program or
did they have to
go back and find
this information
so we were able to query our taxpayer
data
in order to gather this information
um but it's not something that we query
regularly so we didn't have it regularly
readily available but it's something
that once we looked into it it was
readily available follow-up question
follow-up
and
if
a piece of legislation comes that
requires this kind of data and you did a
great job on the numbers and putting it
together
is the dra able to
then develop another program to query
some other aspect of information that
the ways and means committee might need
so for example if you wanted to know
more about
what those taxpayers that are falling in
here
certainly you know we could talk about
which how we could sort of slice it in a
way that could be helpful thank you
director romney thank you chair thank
you
so yeah i guess going back to 2000
whatever of 2018 maybe it was when we
talked about
what what our strategy for conformity
would be
i guess we left it that that we wouldn't
automatically conform to any of the
federal changes
but the dra would keep us abreast of the
changes
and that you would recommend to us
changes that should occur
every year that might make some sense to
us is that correct
that's right we have a statutory
obligation to report to you yearly
by
march 31st so it should be in your inbox
somewhere um because it was sent it was
signed and sent um
did it go up i guess
do you know if that went to the whole
committee or did it
i forget representative what our
obligation is whether it's to send it to
the chair and vice chair or to the full
committee
but it goes to the chair of the senate
chair and the house chair the speak that
that kind of a thing that's right and we
typically send it in hard copy
so it may be in a box somewhere
right but that's the process
and before this bill did you have
opinion on on this particular change
so what's interesting about this
is
um
this should have been something that we
talked about as a component of
conforming to the 2018 code so i think
two budgets ago we had a pretty
substantial
discussion about whether or not to
conform to the 2018 code which contained
all of the provisions of the tax cuts
because
and we did we did in fact update that
reference
we didn't talk about this because of its
specific reference
relative to nols so we essentially
automatically decoupled from that
provision
absent a decision to strike the
reference
to the code of
1996 or 1997 1996.
um
so we really should have talked about it
back in 2018 and didn't
um and so i think that's one of the
reasons why
it was added to this bill because it it
felt like a miss essentially
as a component of that conversation all
right so now we're catching up and going
to have the conversation thank you
representative
thank you unfortunately the conversation
isn't going to have very much time to
happen
right now
but
i was wondering you're you say
uh this taxpayer data that you queried
haven't you just started putting
information into rims
so as part of the rims project we
carried over i believe 10 years
of um older data
so we're not
we're not completely barred from using
old data it's now sitting in our new
system and that's necessary for a number
of reasons i mean our audit cycle
is often three years behind as well so
there are many reasons we had to do that
so we have 10 years of data in the rim
system i believe it's 10 yes wow
thank you
what levels of taxpayer are
i can i can think through how we might
might carve that up for you um
i think
second change the 80
of taxable income
limitation
that undoubtedly
impacts
large taxpayer to small taxpayer every
demographic of taxpayer can generate a
loss and i think
the because what you know about our
taxpayer base and that the vast majority
of our taxes are paid by a very small
number of larger taxpayers
you can infer that the impact of this
legislation is similarly
sort of distributed
but i do think to representative
schomburg's point we could perhaps slice
the data in such a way to sort of
confirm or deny that that theory and i
can take a look at that
but for the first change you can't
well for the first change i think the
testimony that you heard is
probably
what we would find in the data
which is
you have a lot of businesses that are
small that a portion and you have a lot
of businesses that are big that
apportion but undoubtedly the fiscal
impact of this bill
lives with the larger businesses because
thank you questions
thank you
trying to read through this and as i
read through this bill like i have
basically two kind of questions
lines
15 through
22 do they even apply anymore
considering we're beyond the 10-year
period of time and that's just language
we're carrying over that is irrelevant
that would be correct follow-up message
follow-up so we're really we're sitting
on a 10 million dollar cap basically
going forward
and we have a 10 year cycle in which
that 10 year that 10 million cap
the federal government as i understand
the language has unlimited cap for for
that what would be the impact if we were
just to remove the 10-year cap leaving
the 10 million dollar i'm a 10-year
carry forward and just let them carry it
out until they
got 100 of their loss or 10 million
dollars
so it's it's really
a difficult question to answer
because
even if you looked at a given tax year
and said you know taxpayer a
has
200 million dollars in nol that they're
going to carry forward
the state would never recognize a loss
unless that taxpayer had a future
liability to offset and we don't know
that today you know their business could
be incredibly successful
and they could use up all that loss they
could go out of business tomorrow and
never utilize that loss so i would
hesitate to even say we could come up
with an impact because it's so dependent
on future taxpayer behavior that it
undoubtedly would be wrong
that being said i think the risk
is that because
so few of our taxpayers pay the vast
majority of our taxes
that
the implementation of removing either
the 10 million dollar cap or the 10-year
carry forward
if it had a positive outcome for one of
our single largest taxpayers it could
effectuate a meaningful swing so i don't
know that it's so much the cumulative
impact of that change but probably more
the micro level impact for some of our
i guess that is thank you thank you
further questions
this is a question for the chair are we
going to have a work session on this
bill
thank you i just wanted to go back to
something that
miss patali told us about
as i understood it she was saying that
these were things that we have decoupled
from that if we
recoupled
on we would get somewhat more revenue
and
on
163 j is interest expense
which apparently we are allowing
completely in other places or not i
think she corrected herself after oh i
wasn't sure which one she was correcting
i think it's both of them all of them
okay
thank you very much
and i i will be scheduling
a work session on this bill next week
anybody else wish to testify for or
i mean senate bill 4 35
long morning
then i'm closing the public hearing on
uh committee
don't go away i have one more item to
okay you've all been given a
side by side on senate bill on house
bill 355
and the reason for that
is the senate amended 355
and we have to either concur
non-concur
or non-concur and form a committee
conference
so i'd like to have you take a look at
this
and come up with your recommendation
so when we meet next tuesday we'll
hopefully be able to put this to bed
representative herody
thank you mr chair look my question is
why did the senate do this
side by side's nice but
can we get a little
context to it
as to why they went
directly against what we did
i i don't know that answer represent
line
so uh this is my bill and this is i i
sat in on a senate hearing
again the senate wanted to leave it
they felt it was a business decision not
a state decision
uh in in allowing the business to choose
whether or not they uh
wanted to have a screen they didn't feel
the state should mandate it and let it
let it be the option in places where it
works let them do it where places it
doesn't then they don't and and not make
it a mandated state
function so to speak
and that's my understanding too
but we'll make that decision next
tuesday
then
thanks for being tentative and i
actually we got out of here quicker than
i thought we would
you